Well go to your mom's house,
Christina.
Same like,
you know what I'm saying?
Mom.
Mom,
you don't say
that same franchise soon as you know what I'm saying?
Like it's a mirror of know what I'm saying?
You know what I'm saying?
Please me.
You don't say,
Oh la La proper food please.
Okay.
Some spot by matte
black.
Is
anyone on this thing
Jean?
All
time go at great right there.
The ghost crew.
Oh yeah.
Ghost crew.
Those guys were one of the original song makers.
Yeah,
one of the very few favorites.
I think that's my favorite song that they made for us.
That one.
Yeah.
It goes crew has so many great jams.
Incredible.
That was your mind?
Yes.
Those are my jams.
I a Midwest mine.
Oh,
I was in my genes.
I have officially crossed over into Midwestern mom.
I wore my house slippers out twice this weekend with Lj.
Yeah.
I was alone with them so I don't sleep in,
you know,
our kid doesn't nap level.
Wow.
The hounds are really going chasing and I totally,
I had on my fanny pack,
thankfully.
Yeah.
But
she knits all the tagging.
But I did not have,
I forgotten my house.
Smell what?
You're not smell like a different times of the day.
Making sure that thing is on.
Oh,
you gotta make sure you check to verify.
No,
bring,
bringing back.
That song really made me appreciate Dennis Rodman's.
You know what I'm saying?
Oh yeah.
Wait,
Dennis.
Robin didn't,
do you know what I'm saying?
No,
no.
He's on there.
He my while while Blah Blah,
but that's not,
you know what I'm saying?
This blah,
blah,
blah.
Right.
You can't call that it.
You know what I'm saying?
That's a Rodman.
Yeah.
It made me miss him and his insanity and I wish a lot losses.
What's up with him though?
You know what I'm saying?
Why,
why,
why is this that guy that was the best documentary when he went to Korea.
Yeah.
You know what I'm saying?
No,
not,
you know what I'm saying?
You know what I'm saying?
I would load it.
Yeah.
Uh,
and he,
he's meeting with the dignitaries or whatever heads of state in North Korea and
he's just ripped.
He's completely shit faced.
Yeah.
And he's singing grammar carry.
They're singing to him and he's laughing.
And that song also brings back the memory of a Orson Welles drunk.
Yeah.
Champagne.
Excellent.
Oh,
that's one of my favorite things ever discovered.
That's the,
the best thing that the Internet did was,
was bring things like that to people's attention.
Yes.
Because before the Internet,
that thing just lived on a VHS and like five sound guys knew about that.
Yeah.
With the Internet,
all of us get to find out that he was out of his mind fucked up doing
commercials for a wine,
a wine maker and Pramod
and at that,
at that place in your career where you're having to do wine ads,
yeah.
You should probably show up sober and respect.
So yeah,
he's gone and he's still like,
I'm Orson Welles.
Yeah.
Know he's still running on that credit.
Like when the,
I still remember that.
He goes,
I haven't seen that in the years.
And he goes,
yes,
they got like accident.
He's like,
he doesn't do anything.
And they're like,
cut.
Good.
He's like,
you're wasting booth.
He doesn't do anything.
This is waiting on the other guy doesn't have a line yet
because he's supposed to be going like,
ah,
the French champagne.
And on that same French excellence,
so shit faced
man.
Ah,
the French champagne has always been celebrated.
Its excellence there.
Is it kind of fun?
You're shampooing by far my song
inspired by that same French excellence is fermented in the bottle and life.
The Best French champagne.
It's
breath loop.
And he's so fat at this point.
Yeah.
It's real out of breath.
God dammit.
Ah,
champagne.
There's always been celebrated.
Trust excellence.
There is a California
Ah,
yeah,
the,
the forest.
Ah,
yes.
Yup.
They had to know,
oh yeah.
You know,
third tag.
They're like,
this is not going to happen,
but I bet they knew the moment he stepped on set and they were like,
Shit.
Yeah.
But he's so legendary.
You,
I think part of you,
even if he shows up,
I get it.
You're like,
this guy's,
oh,
he'll,
it isn't magic for a reason.
Yeah.
He's going to turn it on.
Right.
Like when the camera's rolling.
And sometimes they don't.
Sometimes they're like,
well,
uh,
the have always been excellent.
He said all his,
his pitch just all over.
It's all over a man.
Yeah.
And that Rodman thing is incredible.
I miss him.
I,
you know what?
There should just be a 24,
seven documentary crew following that guy.
Cause I feel like he's,
he's always doing something ridiculous.
You should know about it.
I agree.
Want to do I want to do a proper show up and then the alien guy.
Yeah.
You're going to love this.
Yes.
It's so fucking amazing to me.
Why is my chair so low?
I don't know.
I laughed so hard at this.
Ah,
oh,
I love it.
So there they certainly don't,
but the point is that China is the one that can come.
The only one that can control Kim Jong,
this crazy fact kid that's running a North Korea
was Randy.
Well,
go to your mom's house,
Christina.
Okay.
I have not laugh this
hard in a long time.
I saw this on my flight to DC.
Oh Nice.
So I was,
I had,
you know,
Wifi and I'm just,
and I see this thing and I'm like,
wait,
what?
And this is Senator John Mccain,
former presidential candidate on,
I think it's Greta van Susteren.
And obviously,
you know,
this topic comes up and he very matter of factly,
it stands out so much because people in this position usually maintain a level
of diplomacy no matter who they're talking about.
Our president's kind of a kick the door down on that.
Yeah,
I guess.
But it's also,
I thought,
look,
I think that part of this,
my theory on this is when you're a pow yeah.
Um,
for a number of years,
you brutally beaten and tortured.
Yeah.
So you,
you have a kind of a matter of fact way of speaking some shit.
And um,
let's be honest,
he was,
uh,
tortured by the Vietnamese.
So I think his whole outlook on the Asian world is skewed a little different
than most people.
Yeah.
So it's
just to me to hear a guy just like lay right into,
I mean,
even though he's obviously is a,
he is a dictator as a maniac,
but he's just like,
it's crazy to say this crazy fat kid running great Korea.
I was shaking on this plant.
I mean I was laughing so fucking hard.
Yeah.
With my headphones in and just like,
oh yeah.
And then the best part,
but we don't even have it here is that he continued after this and she continued
with no,
like there was no pause,
you know?
It was just like,
just like staying here.
You know what I really regret with Mccain is that when he was running for
president,
yeah.
I thought he was the whack out the wacky candidate.
You know what I mean?
Like now I look at him and I'm like,
ah,
oh,
right.
It was president.
That guy's great.
I really like him more now.
Maybe I was too young to appreciate him,
but now you're like,
that guy is Kinda,
he's got his head on,
right?
Yeah.
I like him.
I like the shit that he's saying now for sure.
Well,
I like guys that weren't captured,
but anyways,
guys at weren't captured.
Yeah.
Right,
right.
That's right.
I've heard that that's some kind of a failure on his part.
Right?
Yeah.
It shouldn't have been captured.
Right.
Eh,
an air defense missile is there.
They certainly don't.
But the point is that China is the one that can con the only one that can
control Kim Jong.
There's crazy fact kid.
They're trialing a North Korea
magic.
That's the most magical moment.
That's how I'll remember him for the rest of my life.
Yeah.
He's writing because the thing is,
no second,
nobody is going to defend Kim Jong.
Oh,
no one's going to know of course,
gives me,
are you fat shaming the supreme leader?
But amongst like politicians,
there's usually like decorum.
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
And then they have this,
uh,
you know,
they had this,
I forget what they call it with North Korea.
Uh,
patient diplomacy is the tactic,
but he's just like,
fuck that phrase,
which sometimes you do have to be like,
fuck that crazy factor.
Yeah.
I mean,
you know,
he is a fucking worldclass asshole that guy.
So I I,
you know,
I mean it's not like you gotta be nice about them,
but no,
there's crazy fat kid
11,
you're fat shaming.
Oh yeah.
You're a fat shame.
I'm sure there was some of that.
Well,
do you think anybody's defending?
Yeah,
me too warm in here.
What are you doing?
Oh gene,
it's not that warm.
It's nice.
What are you doing?
You're ruining.
The dogs are going crazy.
Look fiefs on top of Schnitzel.
Yeah.
Faith has given him the business of the business.
I messed up her pronoun.
Did you hear that?
Yeah.
I'm so sorry Betsy.
I just mislabeled your Pronoun while I was in,
um,
Washington Dick come this week.
Yeah,
I did eight shows.
It's a lot of shows.
A lot of shows.
Thank you to everybody that came out.
All our lights are on.
Yeah,
no shows.
Um,
there were a lot of fun and,
and Pat House.
Thank you for coming along and opening the shows.
It's house fat.
No,
every time you say Pat House,
I picture like a really obese person and I know he got wet.
There's a guy named Pat House that I was on the biggest loser.
Oh.
Like I've really fat guy.
That's why I'm,
maybe I've seen it as well because he talks about it on stage because of that.
I house hit up this Pat House.
Yeah,
he did.
Yeah.
One time he was like,
oh hey man,
like,
uh,
you know,
I saw that you have,
um,
you know,
we have the same name and let's be friends.
Basically.
You're skinny.
Yeah.
Well I think he lost the,
this one,
the,
the biggest loser one.
Lost a lot of weight he might've wanted or something.
Wow.
And then Pat House that I know,
you know,
just tells a story about meeting the guy.
Oh,
that's so random.
Or interacting with them.
Yeah.
Wow.
But this pat,
no,
no.
Pat's like fucking 170 pounds.
Normal.
Weighted.
Totally normal.
Totally normal weight.
Um,
we went to the,
uh,
national portrait gallery.
Those are fun.
There's one in England I've been to.
Yeah,
it one's American.
It's fucking,
it's only English there and it's fucking better.
Who did you say Roy?
Stronger.
They're stronger,
number one.
Do you know what was alarming?
So you,
you,
you know,
the,
the hit makers of us presidents,
they were like,
Oh,
you know,
obviously true Roosevelt,
you start seeing,
you're like,
yeah,
you get to this period.
Unless you were a real history buff.
He started walking by portraits where you're like,
never even heard of that guy's name before and it's a prep.
Let me pull this up for as a president.
Yes.
I know a lot of,
okay,
I've learned my histories.
I think you're going to be blown away by
presidents of the United States today.
Have portraits of real celebrities like king asked ripper.
Um,
how about this one?
Okay,
first of all,
does not have one.
Um,
I left a little note there.
I said,
what about the mommies?
Well,
I was going to say that,
that you and I are a list celebrities.
I mean our Internet radio show gets downloaded way more than a lot of TV shows
get watched low to it's seems pretty obvious.
I got startled while you still,
you're supposed to be from this side.
That was terrifying word.
Where are we?
Oh,
so scary.
That's coach ice.
Yeah.
Oh,
that's actually not Cochise another coach,
but other screaming coaches do we have on,
there's a few.
There's a few.
This is a different coach all together right here.
That's a different coach.
Who's that?
That is Horse Morris.
Horace.
More.
That's his name.
I remember her name.
Yeah.
I'm not showing you portrait.
I'm going to give you names.
Coolidge.
Okay,
go ahead.
So bunch of all stars begin heavy hitters.
Heavy hitters start.
Oh No,
not a precedent.
So you know,
so George obviously a big dub,
right?
John Adams.
Jefferson Madison.
You're like,
oh yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
No.
That number eight.
Martin van Buren.
Never heard him.
Family actually went to college with a descendant of the van Buren.
Never heard of him.
Okay.
Uh,
after him knew that William Harrison,
no clue.
Never heard of any US president?
No.
Just for a second after him.
John Tyler.
Tyler,
he's in Duran Duran.
No.
You got that one.
Um,
yeah.
Poke after that.
How about this one?
After that?
This was my most alarming one.
President Zachary Taylor and old.
Rough and ready.
That was his nickname.
Never residents.
Zack,
wait,
how come?
Cause then we have to learn these in school.
Like you have to memorize them.
Never heard of this guide.
I don't remember Zachary.
I mean he was obviously not there for long.
Okay.
But still no one ever mentioned President Zach mentioned old rough and ready.
Oh,
rough and ready?
Yeah.
Can I have your coffee?
Drinking the cold one with the straw.
It doesn't up my whitening.
Okay.
This is fun.
I thought I knew.
Right.
But that's what I'm saying.
Do you know,
obviously,
I mean there's not that many.
So you,
most of the names click something and you,
even the ones that you weren't really studied up on.
Yeah,
but when we saw Zachary Taylor,
Rosa parks,
is she on there?
Yeah,
she was 33rd president
history buff.
Oh,
I love it.
I love history.
I'm just,
what about Franklin Pierce?
Yes.
You knew him.
Yeah,
I remember the name.
I don't know.
I can't tell you what the guy did.
James Buchanan.
Yes.
I knew be Canon history.
11th grade.
Come on,
Mister [inaudible] high school for that name.
They were him.
Lincoln.
No,
no,
no.
Doesn't ring a bell.
Another guy,
Benjamin Franklin wasn't a precedent.
You sure about that?
Yeah,
but then I did a lot of other stuff.
You sure?
Electricity,
poor James ALMANAC wasn't a president chain.
Uh,
what else did he invent?
Let's see.
Pup play.
That was also invented by Benjamin Franklin,
right?
Chester.
Arthur.
No,
never heard of that guy.
Chester.
Yeah,
it's anybody named Chester anymore.
The fucking president.
His asshole.
I like that.
The gentleman boss.
Elegant Arthur gentlemen boss.
But I mean that's going to come back.
That named Chester is going to be a hipster name.
Mark my words,
he was a president,
you know,
in the late 18 hundreds that's one that he should have known.
Yeah,
I was in middle school.
He was fucking was your family in this country?
It was the presidential salary.
Then $50,000 a year.
That's fucking crazy.
Wait,
that can't be right.
It doesn't seem like that's like $1 million a year.
That's not,
that's not accurate.
Because what do they make now?
A hundred thousand a year and make 400 grand now.
Ha being the president.
A lot of money,
Huh?
Fuck,
you got to be president to make money like that.
Would you ever want to date your president?
I mean,
you know,
once you get into a certain era,
they all are familiar because they're more recent.
But go ahead.
Let's do some more.
This is super fun.
I like to know how stupid I am.
It feels good,
right?
You said you didn't,
did you know Rutherford Hayes with for Hayes?
It's in a song.
It's a song or something.
Might suddenly reason I know it.
I know the words.
I don't know what he did.
I don't know.
James Garfield.
Garfield.
Did I favorite cartoon character?
Yeah,
go ahead.
Okay.
Um,
Chester,
we went through that.
What about Benjamin Harrison?
Dude,
no clue.
Benjamin Harrison Arms President Harrison,
23rd president,
nickname,
kid gloves.
Harrison or little Ben.
What are the nicknames now for the president's,
what was Obama's,
does it say Barry?
So Barry and Barry,
uh,
um,
that'd be hilarious if that was a wish someone could hack that site and put it
there.
Bear.
Yeah.
Um,
I mean after that I think you've heard of everybody.
Are you sure?
I'm pretty bad.
It's all on you being honest about whether you wrote,
okay,
so Benjamin Harrison,
you hadn't heard of it?
No clue.
Grover Cleveland High School.
William Mckinley.
No,
there you go
dude.
He's president now into the 19 hundreds.
The idol,
the idol of Oh,
Ohio,
Ohio.
How much did he get paid?
50,000.
The last jump was 200 grand.
I think
it was 200 grand for a while.
He was in Methodist to Jane,
not America.
Okay.
I think I want a second.
I think you've heard of the rest,
but let's double check Mckinley.
You hadn't obviously Roosevelt and a,
yeah,
because I know a couple of Mckinley high schools.
Gotcha.
Uh,
Rosie cause he was a wheelchair.
polio as a child.
I believe.
William Taft.
There's Taft high school.
Yeah,
I know.
A Woodrow Wilson.
Wilson high school.
Yes.
I've heard.
How about this one?
Yeah,
go ahead.
Be Honest.
Beyond saying Warren Harding.
No,
dude,
no,
we walked by,
we've walked by this portrait.
I was like,
who's this guy is just like an old senator or something?
Nope.
29th.
President of United States doesn't ring a bell.
Get what's his middle name?
Jameel.
Yeah.
William Jamal Harding name none listed.
Right.
Morin.
Jamil Harding.
Look at this man in the 1920s.
Yeah,
the presence salar 75 grand a year.
Isn't that,
that's the bandannas because that's,
that is millions of dollars now.
But look at his term.
1921 to 23.
Oh,
he died?
Yeah.
Oh.
So that's why Calvin Coolidge became proud.
We know.
Cool.
And I know Calvin Coolidge.
Yeah.
They used to call him old.
Cool cow.
Cool.
Nutz yeah.
Yep.
Old Slick Dick.
Cool.
Calvin like to smell his own funds.
That's why they called him that silent cow.
He called them because Bart stinkers,
that's his nickname.
Silent cows.
He says,
yes.
That's such a liar.
Look what it says right here.
Let me see.
Silent cow farts were silent but deadly as far as the whole thing.
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
Silent but deadly cow.
Um,
corporate Hoover.
Yes,
of course.
Hoover.
Yeah.
Do you know about,
know about,
uh,
you know about,
I remember.
So little of history.
Do you,
can you remember anything you learned in high school?
No,
not a fucking thing.
Very little things.
If I retained,
you said very few things you said Theodore.
Theodore Roosevelt was in the chair,
wasn't it?
Roosevelt was in a wheelchair,
but not Theodore,
not teddy.
Teddy was about Franklin.
Delanor Roosevelt was in the wheelchair.
Delano Delanore um,
you heard Truman?
I probably that guy.
Truman compony writer for the rest of these.
Let's see.
Let's see what Barry's nickname was.
None.
No bullshit man.
The black guy doesn't get a nickname that shitty.
Is that the injustice of it all?
But some guys on the south side of Chicago could fill in that gap.
Come by.
Bear.
Gene's old mom jeans,
mom jeans.
That's the name.
That's how that stuff came around.
I think because he was making,
they're making fun of his light denim.
Yeah.
So let's see this real quick.
I want to see when the,
it changed here.
Yeah.
So 200 grand a year.
Was it?
It was through,
um,
Clinton and then jumped to 400 rounds with double Clinton was the last of the
200 grand.
200 large.
Wow.
That but 50 grand in what the turn of the century sounds like a fortune,
but it has to be so much money.
That's not,
that can't be accurate.
Maybe it was,
but it made the,
made you really rich at that point.
I don't want these guys now get a $50,000 expense account as well on top of
their 400 grand.
Okay.
If you could time travel,
we have to go back in time.
You can't go forward.
Where would you go?
What era of American?
If I had to go anywhere in American history,
let's start there.
That's a good question,
man.
I mean,
wouldn't you want to just kind of drop into every era for a moment to see what
it's like?
It's hard to pick one.
Uh,
no.
Fuck.
The caveman stuff.
Like I don't want to tell that about us.
Those dopes the last few hundred years.
Yeah,
I guess.
No.
Can I tell you what?
I don't,
I'm not interested.
Right.
I hate cowboy.
Anything like with all the dust and dirt and the gun stuff.
So you'd like to,
I don't want to go to the wild west into 1960 is that you're telling me?
Oh,
I would love the 60s.
Okay.
Yeah.
Put me in like London in the 60s when Beatlemania that's what you want.
That will be fun.
I like fun.
We find writing to be a mod
to be all cool.
I'd like to take my current,
um,
like physique to the 1930s NFL where I would be considered probably bigger and
faster than at least 80,
90% of them.
God.
Yeah.
Or even the NBA like before they let black guys play.
Would just be like a fucking run this shit dude.
Yeah.
I've seen how they traveled back then I'd show up and they'd be like,
what the fuck?
Yeah.
I,
yeah,
I'm way of playing.
You know,
I would do,
I would go to like 19.
Yeah.
59,
58 in America.
Yeah.
And be like,
I'm a female stand up comic.
Oh,
kind of like what?
I'm all,
watch this bitch and then fucking blow minds.
And get arrested and stuff like Lenny Bruce.
That'd be awesome.
Both hats on their heads.
That's what's up.
You have fucking seen these mushy purple's no,
like Ah,
obscenity.
It'd be great.
Be so fun.
Mostly perps mm.
Uh,
the news being like Christina Mushy perps he today was arrested outside of the
purple on.
Yeah.
What's wrong with saying mushy purples?
I could say what I want is just the costing and they would cut the ring.
Like it is horrifying.
Yeah.
Love it.
Her purpose.
Yeah.
I don't really like to do that and then be fine.
Um,
yeah,
so I did that.
I went to and I learned about presence I didn't know we had,
and then I also went to the nat Geo Museum.
And do you know what,
they have their pictures of soggy tits.
They actually had a lack of that.
That's really,
that's all that should be it.
The National Geographic basically have two exhibits,
like the first part,
second part kind of thing.
It's,
it's pretty small,
but yeah.
You know,
whatever,
uh,
the first section,
so half of the nat Geo Museum is there.
Their Instagram account blown up.
Oh,
it's stupid.
So you walk in and you're like,
this is your Instagram account.
And they're like,
yeah,
could have seen that on my phone right now I have to fly to Washington and just,
uh,
is blown up here.
And they're like,
yeah,
exactly.
That's Super Gay.
You know,
Washington DC,
we went to that stupid CIA museum.
We were all excited about spies and stuff.
Spy Museum is for fucking fifth graders,
but they don't.
Yeah,
well it was terrible and not where I like spicy stuff of course.
But it's like for children,
this light,
this one is too,
by the way,
this is not for adults because in Berlin and in Hungary you can see like,
you want to see some shit.
You want to see the KGB museum where they tortured people.
They have that in Budapest.
Do legit like spooky.
You,
you'll cry Lee,
you'll leave crying.
It's so real.
I don't want to see you man.
We don't have that in America.
We have it.
This won't show it today.
We need more tragedy.
More time,
more time.
Um,
now what's really upsetting,
you told me a story today about your experience in first class.
Let's talk about that because I,
it really bothered me to hear this happened.
This is so annoying.
Um,
and so,
um,
probably upsetting for someone to hear me complain about,
but it's still as irritating as shit.
It's not Tom,
it's not,
you've earned first class.
Well,
here's what happened and this happens all the time.
You get on for any of these,
especially for me,
breakfast is really all I cared about.
This happens in coach too,
by the way.
This is not just a first class.
No,
you're right.
But in,
in,
in first class,
what they do is when you're on a flight that's over three hours to serve a meal.
Complimentary of course,
yes.
And,
uh,
you know,
you get your booze,
whatever.
I don't drink really on flaps are not at five in the morning.
No.
I mean,
I know some people that do,
but yeah,
I don't.
So anyways,
uh,
I get on and they're like,
um,
the lady hands up menus,
you basically have two options,
but they,
they printed out.
Right,
right.
Give you your menu and it says,
uh,
this omelet with a chicken sausage and blah,
blah,
blah.
Right.
Or oatmeal and fruit.
So you know what I'm going to have,
right.
You're going to go for the Quito friendly option.
Yeah,
we're going to have it every time.
So I'm sitting there,
I'm in the last row.
I'm in the aisle and I watched her in the last row.
Yes,
go ahead.
Go ahead.
Fourth row aisle seat.
Oh Gee.
Now I watch her go from left to right across row one left to right row to left
to right.
Row Three.
When she comes to my row,
the fourth row,
she looks at me and the guy sitting next to me and then across the aisle.
So in other words,
the last two that she'll hit two women,
she looks at the four of us and goes,
we have a omelet and we have a oatmeal.
And then I go,
so I'm about to say Amen.
She goes,
ah,
ladies first turns.
Hmm.
Like skips the whole way she had been doing it.
The two ladies go,
we'll have omelets.
And then she turns to me and she goes,
I guess you guys are having oatmeal.
And I go,
no,
I'm not.
She goes,
no.
And I go,
no,
I don't want oatmeal.
Hmm.
Well,
she's like,
oh,
I go,
so is there not another omelet?
No.
And I go,
okay,
then I'll just,
I'm good.
No,
it didn't make like a big stink about it.
I go,
I'm good then you don't want,
and I go,
no,
I don't want it.
And she's like,
um,
I'll see if I can find another one.
Which is a weird thing to say,
where are you going to find it?
Yeah.
Don't,
you know,
that's like you saying that there's none left for a reason.
Um,
so I just go,
I kinda zonk out for a minute and when I wake up she goes,
oh,
I found something.
Oh,
you did go.
Okay.
And she puts in front of me like some scrambled eggs,
which is weird because from where?
From coach,
I don't know where the fuck coach option,
I was like,
no,
they don't serve that.
They don't serve that.
They might of like a wrap with the egg.
And coach.
I Dunno.
Uh,
I just,
uh,
I looked at it and I was like,
this doesn't seem like what is on this plane as an option just seemed bizarre to
me.
But it is always super annoying when they have,
we have five of these and four of these have more.
Yeah.
And then you go,
I don't want that thing on.
They're like,
well,
you got the wrong seat.
And then sometimes these,
uh,
flight attendants will pick their own path.
Like that lady,
it's arbitrary.
Go like,
yeah,
we're gonna start in the back row today.
All right,
we're going to start over here.
Since she did the,
you know,
ladies,
first thing I seriously,
in my mind wanting to go like,
excuse me,
you went like this the whole time,
right?
There's a lady there.
You didn't jump over to her.
Right?
So fuck these ladies.
What's up?
What the reverse sexism,
Huh?
I mean,
at what?
We're not talking about a,
they get to,
uh,
you know,
putting their bag in the overhead,
which I'd gladly do for them.
Right.
Were talking about,
well,
why do,
why do I get leapfrogged for that?
No.
Well,
there's a lot of flaws.
Here's what happens now when I'm in first class.
Yeah.
I always try to pick a seat in the first two rows for this exact reason.
I swear to God,
I am so afraid of being passed over on the food options.
Yeah.
Even when I sat in economy,
I would always try to get premium economy.
Yeah.
So that I can get the snack box of my choice because many times I want the
cheese box and then by the time they get to me and I'm in road 25 they're like,
oh,
we're out of the cheese bar.
I'm like,
well,
why don't you get more?
If you know it's a popular item,
why wouldn't you have more?
Get more cheese boxes?
Yes.
Get more meals.
Build bigger overhead compartments.
Yes.
For our bags that every fucking flight I get on they go.
There's limited space.
I mean,
you got to check your bag.
We'll build a bigger,
it doesn't this happen every flight now.
Why can't you build more space?
Who's the genius that design this?
I have fucking two feet above my head.
Right.
Make that shit bigger man or don't allow any.
Then make everybody check them in.
Then there's no fucking problem.
It's so irritating.
And then you see people carrying their entire lives on the airplane and it's
five different pieces he
read.
Yeah.
Is the fuck.
It's always a guy.
Some douche bag guy.
We'll board a flight,
puts his bag and one of the front compartments and then walk to the,
they do that when you do that.
I've done it.
Oh Man,
I fucking,
I could feel my blood rise.
I do it
only if,
only if I know that they're loading back to front and I'm like screwed and I'm
not in a good zone boarding zone cause I know I'm going to get fucked on it so I
won't put it in first class cause I know that's disrespectful but I will on my
way back Boob,
drop that up and rode 10 my ass is in road 20 whatever.
I guess one of my bags up here and also when I'm on d planning than I just boop
grab it and I'm out.
You know
that's not cool.
That's not fair.
And it's always win.
Like of course when like a flight attendants not looking because you want to be
like,
excuse me,
this loser.
No,
no,
I can't tolerate it.
Do you tattle?
No,
cattle
don't snitch.
That's the thing is you're like on the vert you're like,
no,
you can't snitch and he can't snitch.
But it's always like the time where you really actually want it to is when you
see the person board first late and they're like,
um,
there's no room.
Wouldn't be like,
well dickhead.
Yeah.
In a 34 c actually put his bag of shit.
Shit son.
Yeah.
So there is room.
Yeah,
if you get his,
his fucking,
but the food thing always bothered me because like,
you know what the ticket items are that people enjoy the most.
We don't have that,
but we've got salty ass Pringles left.
We've got this,
a coos,
coos wrap with fed out.
Like no one wants that.
You have those left.
They always seem completely blown away when you don't want their dog shits
snack.
Yes.
Come by with a basket and they're like,
yeah,
chips,
chocolate.
And I'm like,
I'm good.
Are you sure?
You know shitty.
It's free garbage.
You don't want it.
I'm like,
no,
I'm good.
We've pulled this out of a dumpster.
You don't want this.
You can have all the free garbage you want.
Well,
cause the thing is those aren't high ticket items.
Like you can buy your own bag of Fritos,
a luxury gimme the good stuff.
Give me stuff that I can't get normally and then I'll be geeked about your
fucking snack options.
Fucking fuck.
Fuck or do something healthier.
Dick Breath.
[inaudible]
this is big time.
You don't know what's going on.
I was in the middle of a great thought.
What do you mean you were in the middle of saying something good?
What did I,
what did I do?
It's about the snacks and I've forgotten it.
Oh,
you said you wanted the Primo snacks.
Yeah.
Gimme good snacks.
Yeah,
I agree.
It's like,
can we Hamas with like crew to tay or whatever.
You know what I'm saying?
So I feel like a virgin.
Yeah.
Has Hummus,
but it was like pretty strong.
I remember being real 40 after that or what about like fresh items?
Chips in real salsa,
not that shit in a jar.
That'd be kind of exciting on a fucking plane or a snack.
Acadamia nuts.
I like those disappointing thing is that you're on the major carriers and they
have the most dog shit.
Yeah,
like Delta American food.
Really bad.
Virgin's got the best food options.
You're right of all of them.
Yeah.
Now if you go international [inaudible] shit.
Another fucking story.
How come?
See they can do it on the international flights were on our way to Africa.
Take pride in that shit.
We had hot fudge Sundaes on our way to Africa.
Why can't we have hot fudge Sundaes and away from DC to la?
Yeah.
We Wa wa Wa wa Wa wa Wa wa or why aren't,
why?
How about lay flats are are from La to New York,
San Francisco to New York,
but la to Philly.
La to DC.
Right.
Just as far as country.
Nope.
Why can't you get away from it?
I'm asleep.
Yo.
Yeah.
I want to sit here.
Only on why do they do that,
that that was so I used to get the lay downs from Atlanta to la.
That was so that's on accident basically?
Yeah.
That's an international,
oh,
right.
They're using to get here before it goes overseas again.
Oh,
those are great though.
Basically by by chance.
And I would always sit with rappers.
There would always be like some miscellaneous wrapper in the miscellaneous.
What would,
I don't know who I like.
Timble easy is not miscellaneous.
I didn't know who it was.
I know I sent you a picture.
I'm like,
yeah,
this guy's famous.
Yeah,
trap God right there for sure.
Okay.
Sorry.
What was your big announcement?
Well,
the big,
the big announcements,
our big announcement.
That is what's happening.
Um,
yeah.
August 23rd
jeans and I
are going to do the podcast live at the West Palm Beach Improv West Harry Palms.
It's very rare that we get to travel together and do this,
but we're doing it Wednesday,
August 23rd it's as rare as a double pipe class.
It's very rare.
We should call it the double pipe classic towards,
Yeah.
It's so rare.
It's just going to be a one off.
There's not,
there's not going to be a second one.
No.
Um,
no,
but it's going to happen.
So if you want to see the podcast,
our podcast,
live cast,
uh,
August 23rd,
we're going to be doing it at the breast bomb beach Improv in flow rider.
That'll be it.
That's just a one and done deal.
Um,
I mentioned this last week.
If you don't know,
I'm coming to mom's Australia,
Australia and I'm doing a Brisbane,
Sydney,
Melbourne,
and Perth.
No,
I'm not doing Adelaide.
Uh,
that is not my choice.
Ahd Allied.
I'm not doing it by choice.
That's just,
this is,
you know,
I'm working with a promoter.
This is the run they set up.
So people have asked me an emails.
That's why it's not any of that.
It's been path promoting name.
Um,
so I'm very excited to go in there.
I have,
uh,
an added show in Pittsburgh,
Pennsylvania.
Next week.
It's Thursday if you want to come.
The early ones sold out.
And then I'm in new haven,
Connecticut,
and then I'm also in Burlington,
Vermont.
I have two shows there.
Yeah,
that's right.
Burlington coat factory,
um,
added shows in a meet rattle Washington that is going to be on the 14th at the
Moore Theater.
The first one is gone and then,
uh,
Portland,
Oregon sold out on the 15th,
so I'm coming back May 13th.
I also added a show in Dallas Fallis,
Texas,
April 20th and I'm doing the rest of the weekend at the Houston Improv in
Houston.
Tay Hos genes did Jewson um,
April 13th and 14th through 15th.
I meant the brand improv.
April 28th
through 29th,
Sacramento at the Punchline,
May 4th through fifth [inaudible],
Arizona and stands up alive.
May 19th or 20th Jude Dork titties,
Gotham comedy club.
And then Denver June 1st through third Denver Comedy Works and then June 16th
and 17th and man friend disco at the punchline.
And then I taped my hour.
I'm so excited.
This is the ramp up.
Did you just announce where or anything yet or not yet?
Not yet.
But I will.
And I hope you guys come to watch it live taping.
I'm so excited.
I'm doing two shows and I would love if Mommy's could come and laugh and uh,
and support and I'll announce it when I can.
Obviously he'll be in June.
I can say that much.
There you go.
So excite,
excite,
amaze all that.
Stand up.
You got to have to do it
Dan.
A wall.
So down stand them.
US stay in a mall.
Dan Umma,
Stan Ama.
Let's see.
Oh this is from a,
I remember last week,
um,
I don't know if you remember last week,
but uh,
the um,
big star of our show was this,
this lady.
No,
I don't want to talk about her when she smells her finger.
Um,
yeah,
yeah.
It's just Raunchy ass and shit.
Smell.
We're going back to her.
No.
Well there was an email about it.
Oh,
okay.
My ass films.
I remember.
Okay.
So she made the point that she hadn't showered in days to be exact.
So the email says the asshole lady is a liar.
Hey Mommy's due to the nice lady and the opening clip.
The how you say asshole lady.
Don't believe a word she says when she tries to make light of her non shower
situation.
I camp for a living in other words goes camping may to December.
I'm camp,
I'm camping Monday through Friday,
so I'm sure you can imagine that means no showers.
Oh Holy God.
Well she has a voluntarily stuffing that nasty pudgy finger into her be hole
after three days of non showers.
You trust me around day two of my rig weekly ritual.
It gets bad.
Don't listen to the lady when she says she wants a dirty ass hole in her face,
she better get her life because nothing about the must is a good thing.
Uh,
about the uh,
maybe the Musk is a good thing as Tom said,
she is gnarliest.
Fuck.
Thank you guys for keeping my weeks in the woods high and tight.
You guys rock Travis.
I mean,
Travis is making a good point,
which is that he's saying there's probably some bullshit when it comes to this.
Wait a minute.
Now you guys are comparing Ana.
Yeah.
When it comes to butthole smells.
Comparing apples to oranges.
Meaning the feminine Pastaria is different in consistency in activity level to
the male pastaria my point Ben Travis could be running,
jumping,
doing things,
real camp camp stuff.
Whereas our girl is probably just sitting in a room taking dumps.
Taking Dom's.
Yeah.
So you can't compare those two things.
Plus we've discussed hair.
Uh,
I hear what you're saying.
I do hear it.
I do.
The court recognizes your point.
Yes.
Yana and it,
she might not be on Travis level of Gnarly,
but right.
This is three days of no shower.
It's not a good situation.
No,
it's not going to smell.
Okay.
Anyway,
I'll tell you what.
I went one day without showering cause our son has refused to Napa lately.
I didn't shower on Sunday.
By Sunday night I was out of my mind.
I was exhausted but I had the shower cause I'm like,
you know what dude,
this is disgusting.
Yeah.
I feel the same way.
I cannot go more than a day.
Unacceptable.
The most I go is like unacceptable.
You wake up,
if you're running late,
you go to where you go.
Yeah.
And you go to bed that night.
The next morning you're like,
I didn't fucking get in the shower.
I mean,
that's how I feel.
I Dunno what's,
I mean,
yeah.
A 24 hours,
man hours is usually the Max for me.
Did a snarl aids.
It's this gross.
You want to be,
you know,
hygenic come on.
I do.
I like the way I shower.
I don't like the funky dude.
We're different though in that you're more of a kick your day off.
No,
no.
You're like,
uh,
get the day started.
Shower.
Absolutely.
I always shower a lot before bed,
so if I'm like ready to go right,
I'm like,
I gotta get a quick shower first.
You know why?
Because my mother taught me that showering at night is kind of bullshit because
then you go in your bed and you're like sleeping and all your dead skin or
you're still,
you're filthy overnight.
I'm a sweaty sleeper.
Yeah.
You know me,
I like it nice and warm.
So I sweat at night.
Yeah.
So in the morning I got to get all that funk off and I don't have a sams.
So
when you're a bear,
yeah.
You hibernate.
I like showering before bed.
It feels,
I feel ready for sleep.
I like to shower before bed.
I like to shower in the morning to maybe I should start doing to shower.
Oh sure you want to do that big spender.
Talking about big spender.
Oh,
a big spender.
You blew my mind.
I've been meaning to bring this topic up for four weeks now.
Cause because he blew my mind,
dude w you know,
every morning I put on Pandora and we listen to nice music and that the baby
jeans,
daddy genes,
Mama June's,
we all have breakfast together and it's in the background and the ads come on
with Pandora and I just,
whatever you ignore it.
I just pushed through them.
Yeah.
And the other day we used your phone,
right?
Plugs it in.
Oh this lose my Pandora account.
And you're like,
I have no ads.
I go,
wait a minute,
you have no ads on your Pandora.
You Go,
yeah,
I paid for it.
And
your brain exploded.
Oh
I
couldn't believe.
How does that hinder?
Or You just suffer through the commercial.
Oh Man.
So much better.
Right.
So here's the thing,
I started doing it.
Well first you were like,
Oh fuck,
I even do something like I really,
it was such a mindblower gene that you pay for Pandora.
I guarantee people listening to this are like,
who pays for Pandora?
I think it's such a luxury,
like it's bananas.
How much is it?
I think it's either three 99 or four 99 a month.
That's a lot.
Yeah.
But man,
when you're enjoying something though,
like on that station,
and then every few that gets a an ad,
it's terrible.
And I listened to Brazilian music so they'll play like Spanish ads,
which isn't Portuguese.
It's insulting.
But uh,
yeah,
I couldn't believe it.
But now I'm on board.
You've converted me to a paid Pandora listener.
It's worth it.
It kind of is.
I don't know though.
It's that whole four bucks.
Oh
sure.
You want us to spend that as Christina for you.
I seriously did have that like
Ford that can we afford
Joey?
Joey would not pay for it.
I wouldn't fuck with Lincoln den or Pandora.
Pride is even listening to Pandora.
No,
not a chance.
There's a 0% chance
anyways.
Bow fucking blew my dog brain apart and you can handle
whatever I'm using.
Power tools,
workshops,
I can't use the doorbell rings.
So I modified a wireless doorbell so that it turns on a,
instead of just playing
a toe,
here's how to make one.
Oh No,
please don't know.
Finding the wireless doorbell.
I don't need to know.
This is boring circuit board immediately next to the AC DC to DC converter.
How boring is this is two years.
There's a chart now.
Dot.
Ac sign.
Signboard more serious.
A dcis is too complicated for me.
A capacitor.
So the whole idea,
I don't even know the president.
How can I figure this out for your brain's dead right now?
We need to know circuit board.
I'm losing my mind.
Easiest way to do this.
It's the chart.
We understand how this stuff works.
People,
people's brains are labeled with a negative.
It's just so hard and negative line at the power supply on the other side of the
positive.
By the way.
No,
the,
I just,
um,
I got here,
you know,
I just got in from DC and I walk in the house and our nanny's here and she goes,
you look tired.
And I go,
ah,
yeah,
I am.
She was Matty tired.
Yeah.
And I go,
thank you.
Yeah.
She's like,
just nods.
Like,
yeah.
She tells,
she told me,
I like,
sorry this morning.
Did you sleep last night?
And I'm like,
no,
not really.
Yeah,
it's very old.
The day.
Very sick
to die.
Cancer,
AIDS problems.
Um,
no.
And I go,
uh,
I go,
hey,
so don't forget this week is our getaway.
Tom and I,
and she goes,
oh,
that is very good.
Very good.
You guys need to sleep.
I'm like,
I get it.
We look like shit.
I know.
Yeah.
I need that arrests.
Thank you.
Have you seen,
by the way of I played for you,
this guy,
uh,
the dresses up like a hippo.
Have you seen that?
You seen in the wild most the hippos.
I've seen a piece of it,
yes.
This is amazing.
Yes,
I've seen it.
Yes.
I'm on the trail of a giant
when it comes to land mammals,
they're terrifying margins.
Oh yeah.
Weighing up to 6,000 pounds.
Oh my life.
That's two tons race adventure.
One time.
My plan is to keep it within arm's reach of these formidable gladiators.
You know,
there is crazy headphones are not happy
are the deadliest animals in Africa.
I believe it.
I mean the dead list is in terms of the kill the most people every year.
Really Hippos more than like than anything.
Lions are shit really shit that can run fast.
They can actually haul ass,
you know,
for,
not for as long,
but these guys can chase a person down.
Just come at you in half,
like split you in half.
Well,
and that's the misnomer.
I would have whatever,
miss whatever.
What they do in children's books.
You grew up thinking that hippos are like the friendliness,
coolest animals.
They're not cool.
No.
Chuck e,
they used to have a singing hymns.
Yeah,
they're fucking lethal.
Yeah.
You shouldn't be teaching kids that they're friendly and wearing dresses and
singers.
Motherfucker,
by the way,
is this guy,
it sounds like,
sounds like bad bite it.
Let me see if this says it a little bit,
but yeah,
it is good.
It is this guy.
Oh my God.
Wow.
No Way.
You guys part two of the bad bike guy.
I got a bad bike guy.
Yeah.
Is it on extraction to,
to get hippo sweat.
That's what it,
no one's actually no sweat.
No one's actually,
I think a con like captured hippo sweat from a hippo in that like in the moment.
Where's sport?
Is there a reason for that?
Why do we need the sweat?
Maybe.
Maybe it's because nobody gives a shit.
It's it.
It's assumed that their sweat has antibacterial properties.
Scientist want to research.
Oh,
okay.
Uh,
so he makes a fake hippo body.
That's bananas.
Yeah.
This guy's a total crazy and there was
one of my favorite clips by,
yeah,
I love that.
He just keeps saying it and he doesn't move over and over.
Yeah.
Good.
A bad boy covered him back on all those ways.
If the secrets of hippo sweater unlocked,
some scientists believe it could result in powerful new antibiotic.
How one block for humans,
but no one's ever retrace went from alive and drug wild hippo.
Well,
yeah,
I'm going to give it a trial.
No,
you're not.
That is not cool.
The one thing is clear.
I need an air hose.
Don't fuck around.
That's one thing that's clear.
The idea.
A hippo hide out.
Are you serious?
Guy's out of his mind.
This guy,
he's building a new suit to apprentice wild hippos so I can get near enough
to capture the sweat,
sweat or skin fucking white people.
Man.
It's so fucking stupid.
So dumb.
This soda.
Um,
yeah.
This is such an old white guy thing to do.
This is how fucking Steve ruined got killed doing stupid shit.
How have we not learned the lesson?
Stop fucking with them.
Some funny posts.
Stake.
Yeah.
No,
it's ready for deployment.
Here's the thing.
This guy had a,
our strategy is to carry the hiphop
had like a,
you know,
a real production team make this thing.
It looks like some shit you'd see at a kid's birthday party.
You know,
like shit.
To me,
if the kid was like,
I like hippos,
you'd throw that in the pool and be like,
there's a hippo right there.
You know?
And then he's going to go out in the wild in Africa with this
so close to them.
I'll try hard and leave me alone inside.
Oh No.
Life is her entire live,
bro.
Fucking way.
How much do they have to pay you to do this?
Oh,
I would be so terrified.
No untold millions.
Look if those fucking things.
No.
Did Brexit,
this guy.
This guy is insane.
What are you doing dude?
I mean,
what do you think it would take for that hippo to run through that thing?
A lot.
A lot of effort.
There's a giant hipbone near shore.
I just need to get close enough to open my,
how are you going to extend the scraper?
This guy's out of his fucking mind.
Did you think a hippo can't smell that?
You're not a hippo and me?
It's funny you bring that up.
Oh,
because
you have a bad sense.
Typos can take a dip for relief.
I've got to tough it out on land and it was pretty nerve wracking.
You saw him,
he got up with it.
Yes.
That was terrible.
Just sitting inside the second not knowing what's going to happen.
You really,
yeah.
I have to rely on my video monitor,
even know what's going on outside.
It just scary.
It's just scary.
Yeah.
Here's what I meant though.
He didn't meet those.
What?
How much do you think he does get paid?
Like you can't make that much.
I know.
This is not for the money and this is like definitely not 1500 a week.
It's more than that.
But he's not making,
he's now president.
Let's just say that.
Right,
right.
Is just overpowering
since I covered this one,
that burnt down so that it's baked in the sun and it just,
so the hippos,
thank you sir.
It's overpowering.
It's high house.
He doesn't do anything.
That's the way
so dramatic.
This guy goes overpowering because there's,
there's a hippo shit all over this fucking fake thing.
Yeah.
And it's just cooking.
So,
but that's,
but that proves the Mortier point of,
uh,
you know,
the hippos w would be able to smell him if not smell these humans.
Course.
Yeah.
Oh God.
I hope he gets attacked is definitely helped.
The believability factor d coin.
The first time I deployed with Madonna and Bailey and a come so close,
my decoy definitely old promise as a stationary blind,
my spirits had been raised.
Man,
I wish this had footage of him scraping sweat and the Hippo Midas guy and Ila
dance.
Ma'Am.
He didn't pay it off with a close and count.
Boy,
I'm really going to bad paid.
Did he get the sweater?
Yeah.
That is the bad bike guy.
That's hilarious.
God I a dip.
She,
yeah,
which just overbearing in here.
That's why would you put yourself in harm's way?
I Dunno.
It is entertaining though.
I'm glad he's doing it.
Yeah.
Thank you for entertaining us and putting your life on the line multiple times.
And that Steve Irwin,
I loved him.
I mean,
he was the original guy who's doing all this stuff,
right?
Yeah.
He was so cool.
It's such a bummer.
He's gone.
Well,
yeah,
it is actually right.
Yeah.
I miss that guy.
He was great.
Yeah,
he really was.
He was,
he was so enthusiastic.
He,
he had a real enthusiasm for all these animals.
I remember he was such a Dork and he was always like,
ah,
it's beautiful.
Crikey.
Yeah,
he was,
his kids are doing it now.
Yeah.
Ben Day and the,
and the sun to band day.
And I know that bendy and Mindy to children check us out.
We have the female version of this now.
So when was the last time you got off?
Oh boy.
Four days ago.
A couple of days.
Wow.
See you probably have a nice big buildup in there.
Don't shoot a lot of sticky.
Come in those balls.
Amen.
Seems to be the question.
Nobody knows the answer to that.
Anybody wants to know?
My detectives looking for the same APP.
Same thing.
Everyone's looking forward.
I hope we find it.
Yeah.
The lot of sticky come in those bars.
Where's the,
Jeez.
So everyone's,
you know,
it's like these people are like that guy in the hippo outfit tiding and
different things.
Trying to find this stuff.
Right?
People.
Scientists.
Wow.
Jeez.
I sure hope we get an answer so far.
Everybody just asks where it is and they say it can't seem to find it.
Maybe.
Maybe president Trump can put some money towards it.
I know he's working on his uh,
financial planning fellow Americans.
There's one mystery we have not yet solved in this country and that is where all
the is.
If you have hot,
sticky,
common your balls,
please step forward.
You know how many people would come forward?
I'm sorry,
how many dudes would Custer president,
Mr President.
I definitely have a hot sticky coming my balls.
Thank you.
Thank you for
serving your country.
Proud American.
You know these guys,
they could have kept all their come to themselves.
They thought about the rest of us and they came forward.
Patriot that I'm going to demonstrate now is the hemiparetic gait shit.
This gate,
if we were to,
you can demonstrate it a walk,
the extension of the leg and internal rotation so the leg is too long.
We get circumduction
with the product side as well.
Is it an epic show to me is very much involved
with the shoulder flection at the elbow.
Pronation of the wrist just tucked under in a cortical fist.
So this is,
it's a retard one bay by the heavy paretic.
What we used to make fun of them go and you make fun of her like normal,
retarded people.
Is this how you pretend?
Yeah,
it's called a retard walk.
Could actually here.
Then you go as well as we have circumduction what?
You're terrible.
What we used to make fun of fraternity people and entry school extremity posture
did,
did the,
did the Quarter Cup posture turn amity,
is there a conducted?
This is hilarious.
I don't feel like I'm appreciating everything.
I know it's so wide as the video even exist.
Who is he?
He's the teaching you to walk like that is exactly it guys.
We all want to make fun of talking to people,
but here's the technical terms and ways to do that correctly.
If you're going to mock somebody,
you gotta know what you're doing.
Now.
Once you find the calm that we've all been looking for,
I want you to pay attention and I'll show you how to walk like a tart.
Ready,
right.
The hemi Hemi pledget gate,
but hemiplegic gait,
hemiplegic gait.
That thing got a Hemi.
That's right.
That must be what it's in reference to be it.
That's a really good or retarded.
There you go.
And there you go.
Oh Man.
Do you think they look,
kids make fun of retarded kids anymore?
No.
When you think of this shit we used to say to each other,
we call each other faggot.
Retard.
I've noticed that.
And the casual retarded on stage doesn't fly.
No,
it,
it's not like you see you fee.
It's not like there's a huge backlash,
but people don't like react to it like,
ah,
yeah.
Like it's not cool anymore.
It's definitely not.
It's not.
It's on the no fly list and it's so fun.
It's so amazing how a lot of sticky,
calm in those box.
Yeah.
I almost wish we could make a tee shirt.
Where's the comm?
But Oh,
we could.
I feel like that won't be a big seller.
Hey,
why?
Cause you expand on your,
I thought for a second.
I just felt like,
guys,
why aren't you buying the,
where's the come shirt wearing it to church?
Wearing it to your family functions school.
Yeah.
Duh.
We've invested in this really cool design.
It's a designer shirt.
It's actually a James perse shirt.
What would it be?
Um,
would it be like a,
like a,
a guy like,
you know what I mean?
Yeah.
Explorer.
Yes.
Looking out maybe some Minox he's glassy forum.
Forum.
Yeah.
Where's the cup or be shrugging shrugging your shoulders.
Where's the fucking comment?
I can't find it anywhere.
It's such an important,
thoughtful question.
No Man.
It's very true.
We're having our mommy getaway tomorrow.
You excited?
What are you looking forward to doing?
Sleeping.
Me Too.
This is sleeping.
Yeah,
we do that.
We tried to just once a month where and um,
you know,
we don't go far or recommend it to any young parents.
If you can,
you have a,
your folks or your,
you know,
you trusted,
loved one,
come over and watch your child for one evening and you go,
even if it's down the street,
you have like a little getaway.
Yeah.
It's a definite necessity,
man.
We put our kid in a little crate and we put a bottle in there and when you put
the,
the blotter thing,
he can let the water thing in there.
You leave them some diapers,
you go.
Just change yourself when it happens.
Yeah.
I'm excited to sleep too.
I'm really excited to just to do nothing.
Oh yeah.
I like to just sit and stare as my favorite.
Yeah.
Staring is a lot of fun.
Or just TV watching's or I really want to drink during the day that that's like
when you can't really do as a parent of a young child.
Yeah.
I mean you can,
but you're not very good at parenting,
right?
You do.
Yeah.
You can have a sip of one.
But yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
It's not,
it's not fun when you're like,
I got to take care of another life.
I'm responsible for somebody.
It takes a while.
You got to do this,
man,
everyone's got to do this.
But I mean I think it's also,
by the way,
it's has nothing to do with parental status also,
whether if you're
single or have no kids,
everyone.
I'm a big advocate for a vacation at a time away.
You got to find the calm.
You got to find that come.
Yeah.
You got to take a break and just look for it.
I agree.
Cause you don't,
no one's ever going to find it.
Well too.
Cause the thing is you,
uh,
you know,
you realize how short life is and you're like,
dude,
what are we doing?
Just grinding,
grinding,
like take a day man.
Absolutely.
Madonna said it best just one day out of life.
It would be,
it will be so nice.
Oh Wow.
Holiday.
She's right.
Bray.
Sorry.
Mean to my manager about that when you're,
I'm like,
where'd you go on vacation this year?
He's like,
oh,
I didn't go anywhere.
I know.
No,
you got to take a vacation,
man.
You got to,
you can't just do this shit every day of the week.
All the time.
Every week,
every month.
No.
No matter what you do.
It makes life miserable if you're just working,
working,
and actually,
yeah.
You know,
I realized that I get happy when I see photos of people on vacation.
I forgot,
I see it and I'm like,
other people's vacation.
Yeah.
Like I go,
no,
just cause I see them enjoying life.
Yeah.
You know,
like when I went there,
I don't know,
over there and the mountains are there in Hawaii or this and I'm just like,
ah,
these,
these people,
like I,
I feel like all these people are doing right.
Yeah.
It's funny because I never,
I never think about life as something to enjoy.
Yeah.
That might just be like my eastern bloc upbringing.
Like it's just not there.
So when we do these things,
that's a little weird.
It forces me to like,
oh,
this is what it's for.
You're supposed to laugh and like have fun and stuff.
Yeah.
I feel good.
And you know,
do fucking yoga.
Okay,
good.
I like her deck.
Yoga fart.
Have you farted during yoga?
Uh,
I've had to fart during one of the few yoga classes I took.
Yeah,
I've had to fart during pilots too.
Oh
yeah.
But I didn't,
I didn't fart.
I've held it like eyes bugging out,
you know?
Yeah.
You know,
I've been singing at karate,
gets in some weird positions.
So I went to see the chiropractor today and I had to Fart when he,
he's like,
okay,
now we're going to,
you know,
when he starts to do the adjustments,
I was like,
oh dude,
I got one in the chamber.
Like he could push down on you.
[inaudible]
like that in front of him.
He'd be like,
where's the Fart?
Or He'd be like,
I found the farmer found them.
I don't know.
Do you really wish I went in front of him?
Speaking of farts,
we got an email,
a double pipe,
classic secret recipe.
Oh.
I drank a Kombucha to loosen up the pipes from Quito.
Baby browns then followed it up with my first ZVM ginger root beer.
About half an hour later,
the zebra gave me wicked burp and my third burp was matched by an accidental
fart that had some serious pressure behind it.
They were both so loud.
I didn't know which was which.
But all I know is that it was the second best moment in my life,
second only to the birth of my children.
Try it out.
Happy Double Piping Mario.
Wow.
Mario with the formula there now I'm interested is are two very uh,
gas heavy beverages.
Absolutely.
And Z via.
You know,
people have different ways of achieving their goals and um,
you know,
this is,
this guy's going heavy on the beverage and just seeing like maybe that makes
sense.
So cause all that gas has got to find a way out.
Maybe that is a secret.
You double up on them.
No,
it's really thought provoking about Mario's plan is that Kombucha is designed
for intestinal health.
That's the whole point is that it creates farts and theZ via,
as we know from this show creates burp.
So you're really looking at increasing your chances of a double pipe classic.
Now there's no such thing as a perfect recipe,
but you can definitely up the probability of having one with this formula.
I think this is genius.
I really,
really serious the whole,
I feel like here's what the,
there's like very few topics in life I can really get excited about.
Like philosophy.
Yeah.
Uh,
reality,
television,
burping and farting.
I could talk about those four topics,
hours,
days,
whole show on him could and you are,
you have done.
I do.
Yeah.
You do all the time
in therapy.
I love talking about mental health.
I think it's fascinating.
Yeah,
right?
Absolutely.
Yeah.
Oh yes.
Yes.
Major,
Major.
I'm excited because I'm going to follow your lead.
You're going to do it well here,
here,
what it's like before you do
so number one,
I had my crown replaced now just like our refrigerators brought to you.
Um,
I had a crown that was bothering me for five years.
Every time I would eat food gets stuck around the gum under it and I'd have to
go to pains,
the floss,
and it was hurting every time.
Five years.
Much like the thing of like,
why don't we just buy more phone chargers instead of having one in the house
that you and I would take turns with?
I was like,
oh,
I should probably just get this change.
So I got that change and it's fantastic.
I'm happy you're already,
I haven't had any problems.
It's just a surreal.
Now here's what I did.
I got my teeth professionally whitened at the dentist.
Here's the thing,
they don't tell you it's one hour and it's fucking excrutiatingly painful,
man.
That sucks.
It sucks so bad.
But one hour,
yeah.
Did you hear the Dang like it looks Rad.
Now here's,
here's what they do.
Pull the plug at a certain,
here's what I did.
Yeah,
because well,
here's the fucking thing.
So I got two veneers on the front.
Those can't get darker or lighter because they're fake teeth.
So I have to bleach the rest of my teeth to match the two friends every couple
of years because your natural teeth dark and with normal stains.
So I tell the Ding Dong a whatever assistant there a couple of weeks ago,
hey,
these are veneers.
I'd like to Whiten the other teeth to match them.
So three quarters the way through the treatment,
by the way,
they put like hydrochloric acid on your teeth.
It's bleach,
it's fucking high powered stuff.
They,
you know,
they put the laser on it and then you sit there with that spreader in your mouth
for an hour while they apply it.
Four Times dog.
Yes.
And it doesn't feel good and it hurts.
And then what happens during that whole time breaks?
No,
it hurts the whole time because like when you do it at home,
that Gel you take home,
it's like 10% 15% what they use in the office.
Oh,
I'm sorry.
Wow.
It smells bad.
Tears come to my eyes.
That was,
it doesn't smell good.
Sorry.
That was a perfect fart.
Thank you.
You really gotta be proud of yourself.
Yeah,
I'm pretty proud of that.
You caught that on,
on,
on shadow it.
And no disrespect to your,
so can you please go back?
I'm just amazed that you got the cigarettes on the pitch and then blue today.
It's always,
wow,
that's spectacular.
And in the professional mix.
Yeah,
and it was right up to the area.
We've got to find in the time code and save it for Alice.
Yeah.
Okay.
Back to my story.
Yeah.
Here's the thing.
The Gel that you take home to do your shits and your trays,
it's like a fraction of the power at the dentist's office.
So what they're doing is they're using the highest amount of bleach.
Yeah.
They put some shit to protect your gums,
but that doesn't matter because it leaks out.
It'll get your gums,
it'll hit your tongue,
it'll hit your everything,
and it feels like hydrochloric acid burning it.
Fucking Hoyts.
Yeah.
So anyways,
I'm fucking there.
At 45 minutes,
I got a tap out.
It's hurting and I say to the lady,
the assistant,
I go,
hey,
how wide are we doing this?
Because my veneers can't lift,
so it's got to match.
And she goes,
oh,
you have bondings.
I was like,
motherfucker.
I told this is what is,
this was the conversation we already did.
You tell the doctor?
I go,
yeah.
So I go,
listen,
wipe this shit off.
Let's see where we're at because if I get the rest,
Steve Harvey White.
Yeah.
And then the front two,
we've done this mistake.
I've done this mistake and know,
you know what I'm saying?
Yeah.
So we wiped it off and I was like,
done.
I'm done.
Tab.
Oh,
you sure we have one?
I'm like,
no,
don't worry about it.
If I want a wider,
I'll come back and here's the thing.
It's pain and suffering,
but it's one hour of it and then you're done.
Versus ut Logan Mays versus taking that shit home,
doing it over weeks and weeks and weeks.
Burning the shit out of your gums.
Anyways.
He made a lot of the dentists do it.
Uh,
I mean,
are you trying to be perfect,
Michelle,
who's trying to win?
I'm not even drinking carbonated drink.
Isn't that something?
Yeah,
but you forget you have the perfect storm of travel day.
Oh,
I know.
I'm not saying it didn't happen.
I got bacteria in Washington DC.
Food.
You've got bacteria on plain food.
Yeah.
Bacteria and La food.
You've got three different cities in your guts right now flying over them.
And then,
yeah.
Anyway,
massive dental update.
Uh,
I'm glad to have this new crown.
I'm just a,
you know,
I'm thrilled and I can't believe I waited this long and you know what?
It's 1500 bucks,
but it's worth every penny.
Yeah.
I'm going to do it.
Not,
no,
not the whitening.
The whitening is not 1500.
The crown.
I know,
I know.
The whitening,
I,
you know,
yeah,
yeah.
But fucking do,
it's a professional does it really doing it every couple of years.
Right?
Of course.
You can only do it so long because it burns a shit out of your mouth and you're,
you're going to hurt.
Oh.
And then the,
the receptionist goes,
now you can't have red wine or anything that could stain a white t shirt because
your teeth are very porous.
Some people don't even want to do the treatment because they're like,
I gotta have my wine at night and want to,
well,
those people are alcoholics
or drink white wine that night.
You LG.
Yeah,
they always do.
Fine.
Um,
this video is pretty funny.
It's a,
a guy in Singapore.
Have you been flossing lately?
You said that was conviction.
So I trust you to do look good,
but dude,
you should profess white
now that I know you've done it this to Singapore thinks that a,
a foreigner is taking too long at the ATM.
So he starts to uh,
verbally barrier.
It's pretty intense actually.
Really?
Yeah.
[inaudible]
whoa.
Wow.
I don't know.
I think of Singapore like that.
This guy has some,
yeah,
some NYC flair to him.
I do like it because he's saying what I think and he's saying what the other
people wanting to sit.
Right.
They don't,
they're not going to say it.
No,
that's it.
That's a difference.
It's called social return.
And by the way,
you ever been stuck at an ATM behind someone that doesn't know what the fuck's
going on.
And I've been the person that doesn't know what the final while we all have.
But it can be,
it can be nerve wracking when you keep hearing,
but you're like,
hey,
you were either withdrawn or you're depositing like one of the two.
Right.
What are you doing right now?
You'd be BP,
BP,
and now pick a lane asshole.
Oh Shit.
Oh,
nice.
Turn it up.
Damn Dude.
Well,
he's right in Singapore.
They got stricter rules on stuff.
Can't you can't take your time at the ATM,
right?
Isn't that true?
Yeah,
it's good.
You go home.
Oh
Wow.
The climax here.
Ready?
I'm ready.
I know.
Yes.
Oh,
stuck out.
Gets out.
Kobo.
Oh Man.
How long do you want me gay.
Wow.
That's uncomfortable,
right?
Yeah.
I mean that's excessive.
Do you want to slap?
Yeah,
it's not cool.
It's pretty funny though.
Yeah.
He's uh,
he's worked up.
Mr Singapore is,
we have some people listening to Singapore.
Oh yeah.
Yeah.
Well,
hello.
I know.
Uh,
uh,
I haven't provided any,
I didn't have anything carbonated.
I know.
Hello?
What the fuck do you think this is?
I like that accent.
Yeah.
There's a guy on Instagram.
I follow.
He's Carlo malty still changing.
He's always talks like that.
He is from Singapore to look gay.
Singaporean dude.
Hello.
Oh,
hello.
Later changing.
Can you think of the name of the dog?
Oh,
no,
it's not a Maltese.
So something else.
That's cute as fuck though.
What's the name?
The name is changing.
Changing goes.
Oh,
hello.
Did it take take?
You got to go out tonight and get wasted.
My dog,
Ching Ching.
Yes.
Crazy fat kid.
This crazy fact.
Crazy fat kid running North Korea.
I know.
That's how like your,
your friend's dad would describe it.
I love it.
Know I,
if somebody who was like,
who are you talking about?
Oh,
this is crazy.
Fad Kid running North Korea.
But that's how our senator describes him on the news.
I love it.
I do two huge fan.
Um,
so we have a mirror last week.
There's justice masterful.
Hi Mommy.
Thanks jeans.
That was during.
Yes.
I've been thinking about it and it was like a hit.
That guy went back and doubled down on it.
Yeah.
Could you improve on something you want us,
it's pretty,
it's pretty impressive as I saw it.
It's like your genes are already as tight as they can be and then you tighten
them.
It's an,
it's another.
Yeah,
it's possible.
It's really crazy.
Let's see.
Uh,
he outdid himself.
It says,
uh,
he goes,
hi blue band.
Thank you for passing along my last video.
Um,
he,
he had ms said,
honestly,
it was motivation to try and outdo myself.
Um,
I got a bunch of other classic gems in there,
but I'll let you discover them yourself,
the girl through,
uh,
through me a few curve balls.
So I had more pauses than I hope for.
Um,
thanks for considering me,
Jean Landon.
But the second week in a row that he just,
wow.
I mean,
it's just a,
hey mommy,
thanks gene's it's inside the hi mommy studios.
It's like,
yeah,
it's crazy.
Okay.
Okay,
let's see it.
Rain,
rain
king.
He's not even at the tower yet.
He connection.
Wow.
Gonna do.
It's got to do,
it's got to plug it in a project.
Plus he's got somebody filling it.
Can I get fresh for you today?
Zella Mae,
how are you doing today?
Uh,
you know,
same shit,
different toilet,
but,
uh,
I've got,
I'm sorry.
Can you hold on one second?
Hey,
case,
when are you gonna move back?
My staple gun,
man.
I'm trying to finish a gazebo.
God Damn.
Do you remember that?
Yup.
That's cut man.
Oh,
right,
right.
If you guys have case,
yeah,
I gazebo even wrapped my staple gun map type music.
A Zebo God damn.
Yeah.
If you,
uh,
go on a Ryan,
sorry,
there's youtube.
What would you type in?
Uh,
either of our names and cut man,
it's on his youtube page is broken down into like 10,
11 episodes and uh,
it's,
uh,
we made that in 2005 bananas.
I'm so sorry about that.
I had a phone call there.
Um,
I've got orders for a couple of different people,
but it's on one ticket.
Is that okay?
Yeah,
go ahead.
Like that.
You would ask permission for that.
Like as if like,
Hey,
can I order food for a bunch of people on the same ticket?
Like they're gonna be like,
no,
you have to do it doesn't matter.
It is,
I love that.
Yeah.
Uh,
okay.
Let the conversation begins.
I'm going to start with the,
uh,
the buffalo chicken tenders or the spicy chicken tenders.
Now,
do you have to in you or do you have three in
wow.
Listen to her.
She's like,
yeah,
definitely through her.
Cause he's like,
do you have to and you were three.
She's like,
yeah,
uh,
let's,
let's do it for peace.
Uh,
you know I'm going to have to do thousand ranch with that.
Yes.
Okay.
So then I'm looking here on the crevice of the menu.
The store down in the hundreds block has chips in a bowl.
Do you guys have that?
Jesus,
I'm sorry.
Do we have one chips in a bowl?
You guys don't have that.
Okay.
Probably don't have hot dogs and Gatorade either.
That's fine.
You know what,
God southern mono sense,
they recommended something for me here.
He's been coming here like 67 years,
so I trust them.
It's like the original butter burger with cheese.
Is that?
Yeah,
but if we're going to skip,
come just to order.
So what,
what'd you like on,
at aside shit?
Um,
let's see.
I'm going to get that with,
I'd like everything on it except onions and pickles.
I haven't done a lot update later.
Ketchup mustard.
I do.
I think that would really impressive part is that this is,
he's not like reading it off of something.
This is all memory.
He'll let us tomato.
That's okay.
Yeah,
I'll update later.
So I don't want that.
No,
I'm saying that's fine.
Okay.
So then for my dad here,
let's see,
that's my dad.
Uh,
he needs to have my dad's dig.
Need my dad's balls.
The cheese balls.
Are you calling cheese curds here?
I sorry.
Oh,
I know this place.
He's nothing.
I want thousand ranch for that.
And uh,
then my mommy's,
let's see.
Zero one to just like a cup of soup.
But you guys have like soup,
like beef,
green chicken cream,
Thursday lane stuff,
Chile.
Oh,
let's,
let's just do the cup of Chili.
Yeah,
that's beautiful.
Guppy um,
and then,
sorry,
one last question.
The kids meals.
You guys,
do you guys still do the pup play?
Kid's meal
pup play
cheeseburger.
Oh,
okay.
It's nothing sexual.
That's,
that's fine if you don't have it.
And then I think I just need to get just one drink.
I need a large Diet Pepsi.
Um,
can you put no ice in that last time?
I,
I don't know why.
Last time I came here my,
I smelled like a butt hole.
Oh my God.
Oh No.
I'm the vault deepen the vaults and then I think I need to finish up.
There's two young gentlemen behind me and they're looking to order,
so I then I'm going to fill her up and sealers shot here.
What's the total wow.
Okay.
I'm just looking at the menu.
Let's see.
Uh,
I got the tenders,
the Chili,
the drink.
You do the math.
Something's missing.
Oh No,
wait,
I see it.
Yep.
I mean,
this was great.
Really well done.
Thanks Jean.
Display definitely know something's wrong and he is definitely on their list of
don't like maybe if there was a lady working alone,
have a guy also stand at the cash booth when this guy drives up because
something's not right.
He's talking to himself.
Yeah.
She's a little worried about Landon.
Which one was you do the math.
You do the math is kicking ass rapper
for breakfast.
250 calories.
Sausages has 500 calories.
How much is that you do the math.
Whoa.
Oh my goodness,
man.
He's out there
quiet.
They're pulling the fan string again
for bean and cheese burritos.
Lathered with two big ass
stupid fucking six sausage and cheese patties.
So Nasty
for bean burritos.
That's about fog or a thousand right
there in each sausage patties.
150 cows.
He's,
you do the mass.
There you go.
There's the origin.
Quiet,
quiet.
Bissell's quiet.
Come here.
Stupid.
Schnitzel.
Dummy.
Hi.
Should I see all right Jane,
you do that I will say,
and the amount of forethought that went into Landon's,
uh,
pitch whatever presentation was,
was a startling,
really good.
They all do.
I,
you know,
I don't mean to diminish anybody hours.
You've all done incredible work.
Uh,
this guy,
he really went into the vaults.
He really,
uh,
amazing.
It's all amazing.
We're rocking our gene.
Of course we are hoodies singular.
Jean Jean.
This is my,
I love it.
It's soft.
It's like a spring Hoodie.
It is not too thick.
It's really soft.
Really well made.
I think you'll love it for springtime.
Spring evenings.
Thanks you guys for doing that.
We appreciate it as always.
Um,
again,
for,
uh,
those who don't know,
we do a live video on Facebook at the end of every episode,
so it's,
it's on our Facebook page.
That is facebook.com/your mom's house podcast.
Uh,
will be a live here in a moment.
And then you would do math
jeans.
Tickets are@athousandranch.com.
I'm at Thomson Reuters.
I can on that top dog is staring and barking still.
Um,
and uh,
yeah,
thank you guys very much for listening to the show.
We'll be back next week with another one.
This is a,
this is who is this?
Ramsay McQueen again with his song cucumber.
Oh,
I'm sure it's influenced by a Kumbaya,
but uh,
that's it for today.
Thanks Jean.
Bye guys.
Hi,
Mommy's,
what
did
you to open?
I didn't know what he did for election on the price
side.
That's so right on the rise.
One thing.
What's going on.